1984 a été une année difficile, nos ventes sont
en baisse, notre croissance est en baisse, je
vous embarque ici pour développer le business du basket-ball,
les gens ne savent pas ce qu'est une Nike,
qu'est-ce qu'une chaussure Converse NBA All-Star,
il n'y a rien de cool à propos de Nike.
devrait avoir un
argumentaire assez convaincant, je pourrais leur dire la
seule chose que les autres entreprises ne peuvent pas
rivaliser avec
notre division de basket-ball est terrible, je
n'aime pas ça, c'est
là que vous avez une
idée brillante que personne d'autre ne peut voir,
allons  l'entendre je l'ai compris je l'ai
trouvé qui est que Jésus
ne peut pas se le permettre je suis prêt à parier ma
carrière sur un gars
je m'appelle Sonny Vaccaro je suis avec Nike
avez-vous l'habitude de vous
présenter devant les gens  portes
à l'improviste je n'aime pas accepter non comme
réponse oh mec on y va tu m'as demandé
ce que je fais ici c'est ce que je fais je
vous trouve joueurs et je le sens cette fois d'accord
c'est risqué quand tu vendais
des baskets hors de  le retour ici Plymouth
qui était risqué ne change pas cela maintenant pour
une recrue oui qui n'a jamais mis les pieds sur un
terrain de la NBA si c'est la
définition littérale de la recrue ouais
quel est le plan nous construisons une ligne de chaussures
autour de lui
j'ai besoin de la meilleure chaussure de basket
ça n'a jamais été fait qui est le joueur
Michael Jordan
[Musique]
tu as notre attention
Je crois qu'il est l'avenir et son histoire
va nous donner envie de voler mais une chaussure
n'est qu'une chaussure et pour mon fils entre
dedans
[Musique  ]
a un nom pour ça
Air Jordan
sérieusement peut-être que ça va grandir sur moi
[Musique]